is a professor at computational
engineering at rice university
and his interests span almost any area
of computer science
his author of more than 500 quality of
more than 500 papers
and for that he received many awards
like the ibm outstanding innovation
awards
the godel prize the carnilakis award
the code award and many others so
today he'll be telling us about symbolic
satisfiability solving
so please moshe thank you albert so it's
a bit strange to see symbolic
satisfiability solving because you think
everything we're doing with such
of course working with symbols but i'll
explain later whether the particular
terminology which may be not
the best one where does it come from
well okay i need to be able to okay so
i want to start with just a reflection
of this
to me an amazing technical development
what i call the sat revolution
that we are in a field that now we have
cost over 60 years really
you can think of roughly we started
around 1960 maybe the first hot paper
was 1950
58 or something like that and very
quickly people realize that this is a
difficult problem in fact we can even go
to the 19th century and see people
realize the 19th century that this is a
difficult problem
and and the culmination of of that
intuition of difficulty of sad
was that cook levine theorem that is np
complete
which led to the view for many years it
was when i was a graduate student
that is intractable hopeless don't don't
bother wasting your time
and then in the in the in the mid mid to
late 90s we had suddenly a
explosion of heuristics started with a
with a
karem sakala and the discovery of con
of conflict a conflict a conflict
analysis and closed learning
and i remember when i first heard karim
talk the first time he talked about the
dilemma rule which i never had this
terminology
and i said who is this guy he doesn't
even know the basic terminology
but it really started the revolution and
by already uh more than 10 years ago we
have reached the milestone of solving
industrial problems with more than a
million variables and today we are
actually thinking of np easy now i'm one
of the people who go around who start
solving
what can we do with such solver because
suddenly np is easy
so this is an amazing i think technical
accomplishment that
i don't think it's enough appreciated in
computer science partly i think we
didn't do a good job marketing it
but i want to be a little bit of also of
the party pooper and criticize kind of
look at ourselves and criticize it and
my observation is that i think we
basically have one algorithm that really
scaled to large industrial problems
and this is cdcl of course cdc is not a
single algorithm it's a family and there
is huge
investigation of different approaches
but at the heart of it there is a single
algorithm
and it is based on what we know now is
this is the weakest proof system and
i'll come back to proof system in a few
minutes
resolution but worse than that
you know because of this is the the the
the so
the risk of success the cost of success
i mean i've you here talk sometimes from
a business manager they tell you that
the downfall of any company is being too
successful
because they just become so attached to
the success model that they stop
innovating
and what we've created in the field is a
bit of a monoculture we are ever because
because cdc is the winning crowd right
now
everybody is working on cdcl practically
not everybody but the vast majority
and to me this is risky practice not
diversifying your your portfolio so to
speak
and i want to talk today about another
approach to
to start solving and discuss its
its success and failure and potential
for the puter potential
so let's step back and take a look at
the proof complexity
aspect of it so we have these
fundamental questions in a
complex theory p versus np and np versus
coin p
of course p versus np gets most of the
attention
but np versus coil p is important in our
context because of the connection to
very very classical logic so one of the
uh
i think greatest accomplishment of the
20th century
between logic and computer science is
realizing that what is a proof
a proof is an object can be checked
algorithmically
and they let the notion of a of a
polynomial bounded proof system
a proof that is polynomially bounded in
length and can be checked in polynomial
time
and this is the np equal coin p if we
have such a polynomial bounded
propositional proof system for
propositional logic
and that led to an area has been going
on since then
of studying the quantitative properties
of potential proof system
and two important results one negative
one
one positive and the negative one the
pigeonhole principle require
exponentially long resolution proofs
and i have to tell you a little funny
story about the pigeonhole principle
some years ago there was a conference in
israel
and we had an excursion and it took us
to a place where there are
underground caves and one of the cape is
called the pigeonhole cave
because the people dug in the the rock
was soft
and people dug holes and they raised
pigeons though
and so as soon as we walk into the
pigeon hole okay people start giggling
pigeon or pigeon hole
and the tour guide said well what's so
funny and we said you know we have a
very important principle in computer
science pigeonhole principle
he said oh please educate me and
immediately i realized that that i
cannot say suppose you have n pigeons
because this statement that make perfect
sense to us makes no sense to a normal
person
so i said i said suppose you took you
you take 10 pigeons
and you put them in nine holes then one
hole will have at least two pigeons
and he looked at us genuinely puzzling
and says
and this is a deep principle for you
and and you could see that he was
thinking
and i have to give two guys to these
idiots and they get paid for being
professor and i'm i'm here giving them
tours
it was very very funny moment so i can
show the php require exponentially long
resolution proofs
but if you go to external resolution
then we can do it polynomially long
proof so there is a big difference in
the power of both systems
and in fact one central resolution is
the weakest proof system
and this still this is the basis of our
all of our such soldiers
and the connection to such solvers goes
back to
uh to a paper by zwiggely in 1977
and he made the observation that if you
have a dpl refutation
a dpl if you're a proof that that fails
then you can just go back and and a
bottom up and transform it into a three
resolution
of the same size of the cell string and
i think this is very important result
because it ties search
to to resolution to proofs
on one hand and it kind of gave us later
we kind of understood the
the the the power of cdcl when beam
couch and in sapporo world showed that
if you look at cdcl
refutation with close learning and vista
these are the two only elements that you
need cdcl today we think of it as a
family
as an algorithm with more components but
just these two components
cloud learning restarts now you
transform into a resolution refutation
of the same size and vice versa
with not a tree resolution now we know
there is exponential gap between trigger
resolution and resolution
and therefore we understand today the
cdcl is potentially more powerful than
dpl
and this explained we can think of it as
one explanation of the power of cdcl
and it tells us also that the study of
proof complexity
is of not just a theoretical interest
but of practical interest and it's
relevant to start solving
and i don't know that we've done enough
to make this connection to how to
harness that the power of cool system
to start solving and it's partly it's
one underlying theme
of this talk so now i want to kind of
jump to to 50 000 feet and talk about a
more general
formulation of rather than just look at
sat i want to look at the border class
of problems
and this is consent satisfaction problem
csp
and so csp is just a very very it's a
it's a paradigmatic problem that you
find all over computer science you have
a set of variables
and you have a set of values and you
have a set of constraints
and what is a constraint a constraint is
a tuple of variables
and a relation over the over the domain
of the same rit as the tuple
and the intuition of the constraint is
that we're looking for what are we
looking for we're looking for
so a solution is an assignment of values
to variables
evaluation and the valuation has to be
such that you look at each constraint
the value assigned to the tuple
x should be in the set of tuples r
so instead of if instead of looking at
arbitrary assignment we are for each
for each for portions of the full tuples
of variables
okay we are looking for restrictions on
the
on this allowed assignments and the
decision problem here is
does this combination of values domain
and concern does it have a solution is
there
global assignment this is global
consistency
that satisfy the local consistency
requirement
and sat is as an example of of csp but
even
clean to me the most the most cleanest
example of csp
is recolorability so we're given a graph
nodes and edges undirected graph and we
want to know is it colorable with three
nodes
and so here the variables are the nodes
and the
dom of the values are just red green and
blue rgb
and what are the constraints for each
edge you form a constraint
for each edge uv we said that the pair
of colors and u and v
must be in the relation that contains
six
pairs of all distinct colors rg rb
and so on and so forth okay so this is
we have
variables these are the nodes the values
are the colors and it concerns each
edge is a constraint this is
non-monochromacity
so this is the the this is the csp
now in 2004 albert for kyon and i
introduced the concept of csp refutation
and what is this or csp proof i i will
kind of not distinguish much between
them because it's a refutation it's a
proof by refutation
and it's a it's a it's a proof of
unsatisfiability
and what is the proof remember a proof
you have
you have a axioms and here the actions
are the concerns that are already given
to you in a set of constraints
so each each new element in the
refutation will be a constraint
and you start from the constraints in c
and there are three inference rules one
is that if you have
um two constraints x
r and y s here rns are relations then
you can take the union
of x and y and get a bigger pupil
and you take the relational join now
you're thinking of this
as a israeli as relations the variables
are the attributes
you have attributes and values so this
is really relation like in the
relational model
and you take the join of the two
relation and it's very
easy exercise undergraduate level
exercise to show that indeed
if the two constraints x r and y as hold
then the join of these constraints must
also hold
and the second inference rule
again is a relational database operation
which is projection
that if you have a consent xr you can
decide to
project out one of the variable so you
delete the variables from the set of
tuples
and you delete the column from the
relation so this is a relational
projection i denoted by the bracket
notation
you take the relation and you delete one
column
so this is a weaker constraint so now
we're kind of weakening the constraints
and another way to weaken the constraint
is just add multiple to the constraints
this is the weakening you just take the
weakening awakening we need mostly for
technical reason that i won't
i won't get into here if by a sequence
of such operations you you end up with
the empty relation
in fact the join is itself is enough
because clearly if you take all the
constraints
and you compute the join of all the
constraints you'll get the tuple of all
variables
and you'll get all the allowed
assignments
and if this is empty then there are no
possible in line and say this is there
is a tight connection between computing
joints
and multi multi multi-relation joints or
multi-joints
and solving csp a disconnect this
connection is established many many
years ago
so in particular we follow that vdc has
a solution if and only if it has a csp
refutation
so this is a very easy completeness
proof of this notion of
this notion of deductive reasoning about
constraints
now this is also connected to a practice
something which is in the practice of
consent solving
one part in consolidating consent
constant propagation
for example in such solving we're very
we are very familiar
with unit propagation which is a very
specific form of constraint propagation
okay more generally both operation
out of the three inference rule that we
saw we saw three inferences joint
projection and weakening
it's easy to see that we could that
instead that part of the thing that
people have been considering
in the csp literature are the joints
they are talking really about how to
combine constraints
and projection usually it is done not as
upper deep projection
but take two joint two relations join
them and then project them back
on on one of the set of variables so you
take you take
x x union y you join rns
and then you project back on x to get a
title relation this is essential
innovation terminology
semi-join and if we want to understand
also the connection to
to start solving then resolution
is precisely if you have two clauses
then resolution mean you take the two
relations the two each clause define
relation which is a set of satisfying
assignments or partial assignments
if you take the join and you project out
the variable on which you're resolving
this is exactly resolution so if you
look at the content of resolution
we do it symbolically not by set of
assignments but semantically resolution
is essentially variable elimination you
take
two constraints you join them you
project away the verbal you want to
eliminate
now another notion i want to introduce
here is that of three widths
so through the composition and i'm
assuming that we are familiar so this
will be a quick i won't even put the
picture
through the composition is trying to to
massage a general graph or general
structure into a tree so you have a tree
and you label every node by a set of
you level every node of the tree by set
of elements of the structure
and it has to be such to condition that
every tuple in the structure
has to live in one of the nodes of the
tree
and the second one that if you look at
all the three nodes that contain one
element
they have to be connected so have to
form a subtree
and in the three which is looks at the
maximum label size
over all three decomposition and then
the minus one
have been driven whole generation of
computer scientists into craziness
so why is three ways important because
it connected
to the width of a of what is the width
of of
refutation it you if you think of
representing constraints explicitly
you can see that if we have a lot of
variables then the size of the
constraints may grow exponentially in
the number of variables
so it's in our interest to limit the
width the number of variables of each
constraint each derived constraints
so the three ways first of all we can
look at the csp instance
and if we just look at all the two pills
and we think of them as a structure is
we think of we have different relation
names and we can think of it as a
structure
so we can think we can associate it
three weeks with
which each csp instance so here we're
looking not at the the
size of the constraints but at the the
collection of tuples on the left side of
each constraint
and that would give us a we could talk
about the width
and the width of the refutation is the
maximularity of the constraints in the
refutation
and the result it falls out from a
couple of papers that
albert faucion and victor del mar wrote
in the early 2000s
was that if we have a csp instance
of boundary with the three within k then
we can consider it's enough to consider
refutations
of a width k so the three
small tree which is is a good of any of
a csp instance is a good feature it
helps us to to solve it more efficiently
we know in fact we know
not just looking at refutation we know
that if we have
a if we are also given the trigger
composition
then of bounded weights then we can
solve the problem the csp
in polynomial time polynomial in the of
the greek a
now let's go back to boolean constraint
which is what i
we want to focus here at solving so now
we have to ask ourselves how do we
represent constraints
so we can do it explicitly by set of
tuples
well as we know this is going to grow
exponentially
in the width so that's maybe an
expensive way to do this
in typical start solving we use clauses
just we use clauses to represent
constraints and we'll talk about
the plus and minuses of that we can use
linear inequalities
in you know if you do cutting planes you
can use linear inequality to do it
ideally what we would like to have is
that if we go back to the notion of
csp proofs we want to have polynomial
closure under joint projection and
weakening
and for example clause are
not generally closed under join i can
take the conjunction of two clauses and
represent them as a clause
i can only do it if i combine it with
projection
so clauses are only clause under the
combination of res of
joint plus projection but if i
i'm not ready to do immediately the
projection then clauses are not a good
a good formulation and that's why we
came up with the idea of using bdds
reduce all the binary decision diagram
so again i'm assuming familiarity with
bdds so i will just go very quickly so
a binary decision diagram and i will not
always says r o b d just bdd
you start with a decision tree for
boolean function
and then you minimize it and you turn it
into decision diagram
and the idea is that at the leaves you
have all the zeros and one
and so you start merging first of all
you merge all the zeros into one
and you merge all the ones into one and
then you go kind of bottom up
and whenever you have two nodes with the
same subtree you merge them there's no
reason to do that
and in fact if you have a variable and
both direction lead to the same node you
skip it as well so this is you're
minimizing the tree
and this goes back to long this goes
back to this
to to to the 70s but it was popularized
by by randy brand in the
in the 80s and the key properties that
were shown is one is that if you fix
verbal ordering then you get canonicity
and in particular because you get
canonicity then equivalence mean
identity
and all the boolean operation can be
done polynomially in fact quadratically
and this says this tells us ability
refutation constitutes a positional
proof system in
in the notion of kukriko in in
particular
if you're giving me such a refutation
i can check its correctness in
polynomial time that's the important
feature here okay i want to be able to
check it
in polynomial time if you allow you of
course more powerful
checking then i can just say proof
system all my old pathologies are axioms
and we are done but we want to be able
to check proof efficiently
and so bdd refutation give us a
propositional cost system
how do they compare to resolution so the
first observation
by alberto colitis and myself was that
you polynomial simulate resolution
because resolution has already pointed
out
is join plus projection and we can do
them both in polynomial time here
and bdd support it and to go from closer
to bdd is very easy a close essentially
eliminate
one assignment so you get infectability
of of linear size ability that basically
the forbidden assignment leads to zero
every all other assignment leads to one
the more interesting observation is that
pigeon or principle has polynomial aside
with the refutations
because the counting what you need to do
essentially there is a counting argument
at the heart of divisional principle
and clauses are not good at doing
counting they cannot express counting
but bdds are very good at doing counting
okay so conclusion from this is the bdd
refutation are exponentially more
powerful than resolution
okay now we already know we know that
extended flag for example
have polynomial polynomial size
refutation for pigeonhole principle
but there is a connection in some sense
between bitter refutation
and excellent fragrant because bdds have
these internal
nodes and you can think of the internal
nodes as the additional variables
that you you can add in extended trigger
proof but it's a
it's a fragment of standard flag where
the the the new variables your you don't
have to be so creative about what
variables to add
they fall out out of the operations of
the ability operations
but bdds are not only more powerful
resolution
they also express other things like the
gaussian calculus if you're dealing with
with zero one
for example with exos and you want to
deal with constraints
and this is actually our main
application i've written many papers
where we look at a
cnf plus xor and there are lots of
applications for that
and again bdds they you know extra
consents no problem whatsoever
gaussian elimination we can do it with
bdds
so bd simulate the gaussian calculus
cutting planes
if you have linear inequalities as long
as you as the coefficients are in unary
otherwise we will have the ability will
can grow exponentially
again we can we can all the operations
of the cutting planes additions column
multiplication
integer division can be done using vdds
so we need this polynomial simulate
cutting planes also
so it's a powerful proof system
so what have we seen so far we've seen
first of all
general framework for for a csp proof
bounded widths and bdd proofs of course
the question is is it any good for start
solving if we at the end of the day we
want to solve satyr
okay can we use it for such solving
so one one possibility which we started
we know it's a complete proof system
so just do exhaustively joints and
projection
and see if you can derive the empty
constraint will tell you it's
unsatisfiable
but then the question is you know if we
do all possible join and projection
we're going to die just like we know
that if you do all possible resolutions
you know we're going to it's going to
explode so how do we
we need some discipline in we in which
order to do that
if i had the three decomposition then it
would be easy i would just follow the
three decomposition i will just follow
the two composition bottom up
and i will just join every node of the
tree of tree composition you join
as you go up you project away variables
in fact we know if we have the
recomposition we can do it in polynomial
time
if it's bounded but in polynomial in
where the the width is the
is the exponent but finding it an
optimal threaded composition is np-half
so this was my work with a with a my
student my phd students in the in the
2000s um
jakuan pan and gochanpan
and we were inspired by what was
happening in model checking
where people start using bdd based model
checking
and that was called symbolic model
checking and
they discovered they have to do that
they have to look at
quantifier elimination there when you
can do the image operation
and if you if you need to build the full
bdd
it blows up and so the idea came up of
doing what's called early quantification
which is essentially a form of efficient
variable elimination
so in general suppose i have this i have
a formula with m clauses and n variables
and i want now to eliminate let's say v
sub n
but suppose that v sub n does not appear
in the later part of the conjunction
then i can first compute do the
conjunction of c1 to ck
then project out vn and then go on so
this is early quantification and in in
summary
join is expensive operation because it
grows constraints
so join lazily and project eagerly this
is in something the philosophy of
of this approach
now we are facing the other question is
well but
how to order your clauses the order in
which they are given to you maybe some
arbitrary order maybe
maybe may not be the optimal order so
ideally
you'll have the you're having reordering
to maximize early quantification
well it's another funny of course
finding optimal clause ordering
is also np np-hard it's related to
finding optimal 3d composition
so in 2004 and 5
pan and i developed a tool called bdd
sat
and we basically heuristic heuristic
from 3d composition heuristic we found
in the csp literature heuristic we found
in symbolic model checking literature
and it's all heuristic about finding
also you need good variable ordering
and good close ordering and we build the
tool and we compared it to what was in a
good
a good solver which was z-sharp and we
started with random formulas
and you see that a low density a density
of one and a half
shafts took no time and
and bdd sat was uh this is a rock scale
so we did that was
was was was exponential in this in this
case
so there was there was no good we said
okay how about high density formulas
now this shaft we know that the the
the resolution is hard for random
formulas
but but shaft was still exponentially
faster
than uh then bdd sat
then we tried brandon my conditional
data also known to be
hard for resolution again z shaft was
exponential but it was exponentially
faster than
then bdd sat but you know we looked at
variety of formulas and one example we
find other other positive results
but one example is is a classical policy
beautiful problem it's called the
mutilated checkerboard
it'll probably have a checkerboard and
you remove the two tiles from the two
opposing corners
and now you're asking can you tile it
using dominoes
and there is a beautiful argument high
level argument that says why you can do
it has to do of course with the colors
but but then you can try to use it to
solve it using using such solvers
and now symbolic was was much much
faster than azusa
and so this situation that are in some
sense incomparable
was was kind of the summary so when pan
graduated in 2006 and the conclusion was
that symbolic scale is better on some
problems
but in general incomparable but overall
i would say you know we could not really
compete well with a
with a tools that had the benefit of
this that at that time even 40 years of
engineering
so all we can conclude is that you know
the symbolic approach has submerit
and it deserves further study
so um what happens
well what happens when the tree falls in
the forest and nobody hears them that
nobody hears it was their noise that's
how i felt about this paper there was
not much
there was not much follow-up some follow
up but overall i would say
this work has not had i was hoping that
it will trigger a lot of interest in
in symbolic solving i can say that it
happened
to part of my life disappointments
so uh in the last couple of years i
decided to go back to
to see what is the potential of a
symbolic star solving
and now my interest is in in in model
counting
which comes from applications in a in ai
specifically in probabilistic inference
so
sharpshot is counting the number of
satisfying assignments
and this is a harder problem we know
it's a sharpie complete
but it is very also very important
problem in practice and in particular
especially if you're coming from
holistic reasoning it's not just about
uh just number of assignment but the
this the sum of the weights of
assignments
so the assignments are awaited in
particular one popular model is called
literal
weighting in which each literal has a
weight positive and active israel has a
weight
and the weight of an assignment is the
product of all the literal weights
and then you take the sum of all the
weight of the satisfying assignments
now because we're trying to reason
numerically we can just use
a binary decision diagram but you we use
algebraic decision diagram
so the same way that bds represent
boolean functions
adds represent pseudo boolean functions
and again it's a
it's the same idea of the folded
decision tree where the internal load
correspond to your branch on
decision diagram and boolean variables
but instead of having the zero one
as leaves you can hit arbitrary many
leaves and they are labeled with real
numbers
i mean floating point or in fact some
some packages let you use infinite
precision numbers
and again they have nice properties and
you people have used them for example
in probabilistic model checking when you
want to compute probabilities
people have used adds they've been
successful very successful for
symbolic probabilistic model checking
so we can do weighted model counting
with adds
how do we do it we start with the with
the boolean
formula we compute the bdds
we add the weights and we turn this bdd
into an 80d that gives you the weight of
each assignment
and now you need to do variable
elimination all the variables but you do
you do the quantitative analog
of what's called shannon expansion
channel expansion said that to eliminate
the variable
you take the disjunction of of the
assignment zero and assignment one
and here you take the sum because this
is now the sum
we're computing sum of f of weighted
assignments this is now the sum
of a of p goes to zero and ap goes to
one
again the problem is that that it's
going to be
it's going to blow up if you try to
compute even just the bdd it will blow
up
so um my students
dudek and and fun and myself we
went again we looked at a what do we do
and we were inspired by bddsart
and again we want to do early
quantification and so
addmc was a add-based model counter
that was we start from the bdds and you
had early quantification
what do you see here the best uh
solver is it was a solver called d4
based on what's called knowledge
compilation i won't get into detail
turns out that it's very hard to find
the best uh counter
so what became popular in this community
is looking what called vbs virtual best
solver so you have a portfolio of
solvers
and for which instance you look what is
the best outcome that you get
and one other thing we want to see here
is what happened we have a set of
solvers
we're throwing one more solver how much
does it improve
the vbs so if you see here vbs0 is the
green line
and vbs1 is a blue line where we've
added addmc
and you can see that we have solved
about
in this case about a 150 additional
formulas
so so the portfolio improve when you
take
a portfolio of solver and you add addmc
the portfolio improved by about 10 of
the formula you consult before you can
solve now
so it's a good addition to the portfolio
and of course everybody would love to
have
the best the winning algorithm and
that's very hard to to find these days
but we're looking at the portfolio
now i want to go back we're just about
to wrap up i want to go back to 3d
compositions
remember in 2005 so to the decomposition
solve
3d composition computing is very hard
indeed
optimal to decomposition is hard but a
huge progress
since then in in practical 3d
composition solving
and the tools are getting better and
better and they are not optimal
but they have another advantage to
become any time solver as you let it run
more and more you get better and better
result
so in the past year again
jeff dudek and wufan and myself look at
what we call not dpmc
and so again the idea i use early
quantification but
now instead of using sp csp heuristic
use three decompositions
and it turned out going from from csp
wasting to the composition gives us a
huge advantage
and dp dmpc actually it's the
dynamic is deep is a typo dpmc dynamic
programming model counting
it is much faster than addmc
and it tied for first place in the most
recent competition of model
model county competition for in the
weighted track
but again what you see is know that it
is the best model counter
it improve improve the virtual best
solver significantly
and you can see we are now getting
closer we have a larger benchmark and
using this portfolio of a whole bunch of
solver
you add the pmc and now again you're
you're solving about 10
more formulas so let me try to wrap it
up
um i think symbolic technique or bdd
decision diagram when i say symbolic i
really mean decision diagram techniques
to give us
a viable approach to boolean reasoning
there are add important addition to
their portfolio
and unlike what happens in in academia
when you go to industrial tools
they are almost always portfolios
because the people
unlike the people the people in industry
care about solving problems
not about publishing a paper and so they
they saw the kitchen seeing the problem
and and it for the future it's it's
reduction in is a powerful tool
but at the end start solving or
reasoning such reasoning will be using
algorithmic portfolios
and one question that i think we need to
ask ourselves are the competition
somehow discouraging
you know they're pushing you towards
this reductionist approach in fact when
sadzilla came about people say oh no no
we can't allow that
so let's let's make sure we're not using
portfolios
maybe we need to do more research about
portfolios because that's the way it's
going to be in industry
the bigger questions are are a you know
search is very powerful technique
and and in fact cdcl is a is extremely
powerful combination of search and
reasoning
and unless we find a way i think to
combine certain symbolic techniques
this will not this this to me is what
the next step is
another question is you know again one
of the success of sat was it was very
easy to generalize it to smt
can we take a symbolic reasoning how do
we combine bdds with with a
with smt so i'm trying again to get the
community interested
in in broadening our research agenda
thank you very much
thanks a lot moshe for this very nice
talk
so we have a lot of time for questions
um
so i suggest that you write the
questions in the chat
or raise your hand or even
unmute yourself if you're not allowed to
so let me see
there is a question from victor miller
says were you able to even vaguely
characterize the problems
in which addmc or dpmc
did best yes yes actually we have
not vaguely even even more clearly it
has to do with the
with the three weeds so in fact we
we pretty much know that if we have a
a small three wheats and small i don't
remember exactly the number
i mean it's it would be maybe let's say
50
but don't we don't grab you on that if
we have but i mean it's still large in
the sense 250 is a very large number
but in practice if we have if we have a
width of uh
less than 50 then this this uh three
decomposition based tools do actually
quite well
and in fact a good portfolio heuristic
would be to use this anytime solver give
them a time budget
see can you get to 3d composition
of of of this bound of the magical bound
and if not go use d4
d4 use a monolithic approach use
knowledge compilation
but rather than dynamic programming and
i think in fact this tool
if we combine a a
dpmc with d4 with this very simple kind
of portfolio heuristic very simplistic
heuristic this would immediately give us
the best the best tool in the
in the uh so far available so far
okay there's another question from cool
deep
since it looks symbolic reasoning did
well for counting and search
and search is really good for np what do
you think about problems in between like
2 pbf or 3kb
so uh way way back in the past again
going back to my student got champagne
he also tried these two for for qbf
and that has not worked very well at the
time
and he ended up developing a tool that
actually tried to combine
a bdd reasoning with resolution
so there is there is a variant of vdd
called called zdd
zero suppress decision diagram and you
cre you can use it to represent close
sets of clauses
compactly so remember part of the
problem is and this would be interesting
i think even too i think
people have may have explored it in the
context of sat maybe
current probably knows about this and so
if you have a very large set of clauses
then it does become a problem
and so what zidane able to do the
ability to reason about clauses but
symbolically
and we built then a solver qmres which
was
did symbolic resolution and for
deep alternation actually not for
shallow alternation for shallow
alternation
still search-based tool were better but
if you went to deep alternation and for
example you take benchmark that
translates a
benchmark from a modal logic to qbf
and you end up deep alternation and for
depaul donation at the time in fact
was was the with the tool of choice in
in for deep alternation 15 years ago but
as as happens in academia students
graduate
and they they move on and now we even
have a problem
running the tool because we did not do a
good job of creating a package with no
dependencies so even running the tool is
a challenge
but yes i think we should explore
symbolic but even there symbolic
when i say symbolic we it doesn't just
mean bdd based we need to think more
bodily about what symbolic mean i think
in some context zdd's actually would
give us the
the right combination of thinking but
combining clauses with symbolic
representation
more questions mate is asking
portfolios are explicitly scoped out in
the set competition
and using a portfolio in the model
counting competition was so much
unexpected that the competition had to
be rerun
but winning this competition is one of
the
surefire way to have higher number of
citations what should we do
i mean the the question is again is how
to do how to
you know not to throw the baby with the
with the water in the bathtub right
so um i think with what we need to do
i would say is create separate tracks in
some one way to try to do it is to have
a reductionist tract and and a portfolio
truck
so i mean just in very often if you
if i would go if i were to compete in
for example basketball i could never
play serious basketball
because my height is 170. i think they
should create if they've created a
basketball track for people between 165
170 i might have become a professional
basketball player
but as it is i never had any chance so
but in other area in in wrestling we
have trucks right we create different
tracks for different
weight classes so i think we could
it's worthy to put portfolio as a
subject deserve to be studied
but we need to separate it from the from
the single attack
singular solver attack
yeah i have a comment here there
oh sorry i get an x
uh so so there's like a no limit track
which exactly for this purpose
so so there was in 2013 was kind of the
the clash of these cultures portfolio
but it was not i think karem was
actually
judged back then this was a really very
debated
time and since then like the the main
track did not allow portfolios but there
was always a separate track
which was called no limit and you could
like submit anything
but people stopped so so what happened
in the last like i don't know four or
five years was that
there was no portfolio silver anymore in
this track
and so so it's not like the organizers
of the competition it's like the
submitters
and i have a second comment so there's a
very nice paper by
randy pry and then marvin hoyley coming
up which is about symbolic
bdd-based start solving attackers
actually so you might check that out
yeah actually i've heard he he gave a
talk for my seminar yeah i think this is
the one follow-up i've i haven't seen it
i've seen the preliminary version hasn't
published yet but
is it accepted somewhere do you know
what's the status
okay okay okay yeah very good yeah so no
and of course andy was able to take some
cases where we were struggling and he
i would expect randy bryan to add some
to improve it and lead to much better
performance um so i i
it'd be nice to see more people looking
for non-non-city cell
there were some i remember i had some
communication with the computer at some
point and in fact they tried to create
non-cdc altera
and i think even that did not for you're
right i'm not trying to blame when i say
competition i'm definitely not trying to
blame
to blame the competition organizers i'm
talking to us are we all in it i mean
the competition organizer and the
competition submitter are all one part
of one community
i think we the community needs to figure
out what are they
how do we create more proliferation of
approaches and
different things in competition a very
powerful tool
so we need to think how to leverage it
how to make it even more successful
in particular to neglected areas there
was one
question from some bus is asking about
combining search and symbolic methods
so have there been any attempts to bring
techniques from cdcl solvers into bdd
solvers
like backtracking or close learning so
what what
i have we are now i have now a project
of students that are working on
essentially trying to use somewhat of a
search
but not pure search but can we use a
instance of parallel search to
parallelize this
this approach by essentially starting
with searching on a set of variables and
then splitting the problem
and sending to different calls and we
will we will know very soon how
successful
so this is but i think i think one of
the nice thing about
a about cdcl is not is a is a very
i would say it's a very smart
combination of
of search and proof so to speak and it's
smart in the sense that if
doing kind of what we do is we know from
the problem with that this problem
emerge
early on if you just do all resolutions
you die
you die because there are too many too
many resolvent right
and the idea here is to use the search
to guide resolution
and i think this is really a brilliant
idea that we i don't think we fully
understand the power of this idea
and the question is can we use this idea
and broaden it beyond resolution right
now the way it works at this
as i said galileo observed in the in the
pure splitting if you just combine it's
really give
its resolution but i think this is a
very powerful idea
that that karem discovered in the 90s
that you can let search guide the
resolution
and the question is can we let's search
guide more than just a resolution can we
let search guide
you know cs like the joins and maybe
in hyper in in extended phrase can
search guide introduction of variables
and so on and so forth
i i think they deserve further study if
i may
uh i think you're giving me too much
credit for the idea uh
moshe the idea of of conflict-driven
learning and and and learning from
search to uh to guide resolution
was started in the early 70s with the
truth management maintenance systems you
know for
for uh uh cp's you know mit medical
diagnosis
they were calling them no goods i think
what made it work so well for cs
uh uh um for sat is the fact that the
learning
is of the same form as the input yes
the constraints are uniform in that
sense so that's what made it work so
well
yeah i don't know if you can find i
think the nature of it
of the constraint is important here you
know you have different kinds of formats
yeah but let me give you an example so
there are many applications in which we
need
we get a set of constraints but the
consensus are border than just clauses
we have xors we have cardinality
constraints
think about it bdd is give them exo no
problem
greater than other consensus no problem
so we cannot do it's
you know resolution does not work there
by joining projection would work equally
well
and so we have the potential i think if
we can think beyond if we can find a way
to combine in such a way we we have the
option of
generalizing these ideas and to me this
is one of the challenges can we take the
the key ideas that have led to so much
success in cdcl
and are they just specific to cdcl
or can we somehow find the essence of
these ideas and carry them to
even larger success in dealing with
wider class of constraints
so now going back to this idea of
symbolic solving
if i may ask a question myself so i know
that
another area that you're it's very much
deep in your heart is automatic theory
yeah and in in symbolic uh model
checking that's used a lot
and bdds in some sense they can be
thought as automata where
the length of the input is just fixed
right yeah yeah that deterministic
there are dfa b2ds or dfas essentially
yeah so the question the question is of
course an automata we have
this concept of non-deterministic
automata even alternating automata which
is plays a very key role in
in symbolic model checking so what about
using them here is there any attempt
to using this method um so
um so we have used of course we use
a vdds a lot for reasoning for example
when
also pan also did work on using model
solving
so the model solving you is really if
you look at the
satisfiability for mondologic it's about
using three automata
and you know again a tree automata is
essentially the end of the game the
waves of zero automatize
is a it's a two-player game and you
solve you solve the the winning winning
states and you could do it symbolically
so again he built a
built a solver for monologic
k for the basic modal logic again using
using bdds
the interesting thing is about when we
do all these sophisticated automotive
therapeutic reasoning
we're always then reducing to
deterministic automata because that's
what what we can manipulate
efficiently okay so
the exception is satisfiability but when
we do for example
temporal synthesis it's about
deterministic automata
and even even you look at the
you know the reduction to parity
automata when you look at the heart of
what's happening
it is reasoning with deterministic
automata
so and we people have looked i have
looked to the girl some italian caller
get a
symbolic party game solving also
building on on uh
on bts when you have more powerful
automata
it becomes very directly for example
they are not closed under various
operations
so the way we get the closure is we
reduce them to the municipal autonomous
and dominican automata are very very
close to bdds the bdds are essentially
music automata
with skipping irrelevant letters
so it's a bit like bit blasting in some
sense right where you're reducing to a
less expressive model and yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah and i have to tell you we we i have
tried hard to
to say well this is stupid we should be
able to be smarter than that
and we had lots of failures along the
way of trying to be
smarter than be blasting in on doing
on look with working with automata yeah
okay so thank you very much uh we're
very much on time so
let's thank moshe again for this
fantastic talk
we upload for everyone and now we're
going to take a break
before karen will give us his talk
so we'll resume having this five-minute
break so we'll resume at 9
30 pacific time thank you very much
moshe again
yep my pleasure